is there some something you can give
color to the drama Erica's talk Eric
Weinstein has spoken about some of the
challenges some of the triumphs and
challenges of his time at Harvard so
is there some something to that drama of
people stealing each other's ideas or
not allocating credit enough oh sure yes
um all of that and and creating
psychological stressors because of that
help us all the time yes unfortunately
on young minds and so on could have a
very bad effect is that just the way of
life or is this
um I think we can definitely do better
and I think the first step is to kind of
admit that we are not 100 Seekers of
truth that we are human beings and all
the
The Good and Bad and The Ugly
qualities
um can be present and to have some kind
of dialogue in my subject in mathematics
this has not happened yet there have
been some famous cases where people have
been accused which had been resolved or
partially resolved or unresolved and uh
everybody knows it but there isn't a
systematic effort as far as I can tell
of really trying to create some rules
some ethics rules this is this is fair
game this is not fair game so that as a
community we strive to get better
I think that for most people it's more
like keeping your head in the sand and
kind of pretending that it doesn't
happen or it happens some isolated
incidents well I don't my experience is
not like that at all I think it does
happen much more often than it should
that's my opinion uh so there's the pool
of Academia is fascinating uh one of the
reasons I really love it is you have
young minds with fresh ideas
and that that same innocence you had
when you first on the train have that
brilliant breakthrough and then you
throw that in together with senior
exceptional world-class scientists who
have first of all are getting older
um second of all maybe they have
partaken in the drug of Fame and money
and status and recognition so that
starts to a little bit corrupt all of
our human minds and you throw that mix
in together yeah
mostly without rules
and uh is beautiful because that's where
the ideas of old
contend with the the new wild-eyed crazy
ideas and they clash and there's a
tension and it's there's a dance to it
but then there's the old human
corruption that can take advantage of
the young minds
um it's unclear what to do with that
I mean part of that is just the way of
life and the strategies
um and oftentimes when you look at who
wins the Nobel Prize it's also tragic
because sometimes so many
minds are like the trajectory to the
Breakthrough idea involves so many
different Minds young and old yeah I
mean
you're right it's I think it's like
everything else the the through the the
path is to more self-awareness and it's
like owning up your own
stuff and uh not blaming other people
not projecting onto other people but
taking responsibility
and that's true for everything and
the problem here unique problem for
mathematics I would say physicists and
chemists are better they have they
actually have better sort of ethical
rules and so on special biologists like
because I think in part it's because
there is much more money involved
because they have to get grants and so
on so for them the question of priority
who discovered what first is much more
serious because there's really some
serious money mathematics who cares you
know that Famous Last Theorem was proved
yeah did Andrew Wells become a
millionaire no but I think you want a
price but those prices are not I think
that one was a big prize but uh but in
general there's not going to keep I
think he won the Abel prize eventually
which is about a million dollars so but
you know I sometimes I joke about this
that this is the hardest way to win a
million dollars
so you know
but amongst mathematicians I think the
trouble is that we are so insulated
from a society because it's such a pure
subject it draws in very specific uh
psychological types and I can speak
about myself I did not realize it at the
time but later on I definitely saw I
mentioned some of it earlier that for me
mathemax was a refuge from the cruelty
of the life I experienced from
discrimination that I experienced when I
applied to Moscow University at 16 being
failed at the exam and stuff like that
which I described in my book as well but
um that was my way I was like I don't
trust this world I don't want to deal
with it
I want to hide in this platonic reality
of pure forms
this is where I know how to operate I
love this and and I couldn't be bothered
in some sense for a while it happened up
to a point as as I was getting older and
more mature I was becoming more and more
interested in other things
but I think that's one of the reasons
and one of them
reasons why I wrote Love and math
was precisely to break that cycle
that it's it's the quiet guy in the
corner that goes into math and not the
flamboyant you know a joke or like you
know a DJ
I wanted to show
uh
how beautiful the subject is to attract
this new blood so that different
psychological types and
more women
would join because then they would have
students who would look at them and whom
they will inspire and then it would be a
instead of a vicious circle it would be
a virtual Circle and I have to say I
think it's happening not because of my
efforts on alone obviously there are
many other mathematians who are around
the same time started to put more effort
because see if the old stereotype of
mathematician is so enclosed you're not
interested in even exposing the beauty
of your subject to other people you see
and then it becomes this vicious circle
but you know this one day you know I not
one day all the time I meet I meet these
students who say
your book is the reason why I chose math
as my major and I am proud especially
when it's women who tell me this and
they are cool they are DJs at the same
time and they are social and they have
friends and they go out and so on you
see so they are then they carry the
torch because then they will be more
likely
to
share this beauty with others to attract
more students and so on so I think this
this kind of that's done was broken so
now you'll have more influx and once we
have people who are more can able to
connect at the personal level that's
when we also become more self-aware as a
community I think and that's when we
might be we should be able to have a
chance to improve in terms of our
ethical rules and stuff like that